hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trading census.com
i'm a professional trader and i'm here
to teach you everything i know about
technical analysis
so that you guys can use it to set up
your trades so what i like to do is to
go
through charts and use all the
indicators that work for me so that i
can show you
how to use it and what signals you have
so today
let's do this with gamestop let's get
into it
okay guys so i do regular updates on
gamestop
i like to post at least one or two
videos
a week sometimes three and i like to go
through the analysis that i did
and see if i was correct or not and if
my scenario is
still my preferred scenario is still
valid or not
so to do that first let's remind what
was my last scenario
so i was telling you for the past week
that we are bullish actually i was
telling you that we are waiting
you know to break this level the 160
level
uh that would probably be broken
retested and then we would go higher
so i was bullish since the 26th
of april and my accounting that i did
last time was actually this one right
so i was expecting that a third wave
would happen
i was telling you that we should have a
strong move up coming soon
and that it would probably happen on
monday uh because i was expecting the
macd
on the daily time frame which is very
used by asset managers and big
institutional clients to turn
positive and guys this is exactly what
happened
so right now what is the situation i was
telling you in the last video i did so
this one i did it one week ago i was
calling for this strong move up and in
the last video i did
i was telling you that we would probably
go to the 216 level
around the fourth of may so this is
tuesday
so let's see for now this is still
possible uh we have two
days uh left and that we i think
gonna get rejected and break it in the
third wave all right
so if this scenario is the good one this
needs to happen
soon and once again the only thing that
i'm missing
here is some stronger volumes guys i
don't have
very strong volumes so even on this very
bullish day the volumes you know they
were okay the biggest that we had
uh in the past two weeks but it's much
lower compared to
the volumes we had uh during the whole
gamestop story
so this is the one indicator that
is not giving me good signals but let's
do the other indicators
and uh see what they are telling us
so moving averages very easy to use 20
50 and 200 period moving average
this is just basically gonna give you so
of course some support or resistance
level depending on the side of it you
are
but the most important information that
it's gonna give you
is just bullish or bearish right easy
and if we are above all of the three
moving averages this is bullish
and if the moving averages are actually
in the
period order so here 20 the shorter one
50 the second shortest one and 200 the
longest one
so and they are in the right order as
you can see
so this is telling you that the bullish
sentiment is very positive all right
this is intact so this is actually what
we are expecting in the third wave
we don't expect to see any crossover of
this moving averages
uh let's see on the hourly timeframe how
it is
same you can see even on the hourly
timeframe now we are
in the right order the 50 just crossed
the 200 period one
here so you can see the price action is
not doing anything
but the moving averages are going higher
because the past
you know price action is getting out of
the table and we are taking into account
new moves that even if they are flat
it's still better
than a bearish move that we had 50
period ago
so this is the reason why the 50 period
moving average still
goes higher some moving averages are
giving us
bullish signals i mean it's not really a
signal it's the confirmation that the
bullish case
is the preferred scenario for now then
what i like to do is to use fibs so to
see if the retracement we're having here
so you guys maybe
are worried oh it's it's you know we had
this strong
bullish day and then we lost you know 30
or 50 percent of this
strong move up and we are not going
higher is this a problem let's check if
we are in the bearish or bullish zone
using fibs so you measure the last wave
so here you are wondering about the
retracement of this first wave
so you measure it very easy
and you just see which side we are so if
you are trading above the 50 percent
retracement level
this is bullish and here you can see
that on the four hours time frame we
have never broken the 50
retracement level we dip down very
quickly
uh to the you know one point uh 0.618
retracement level
but we mostly stayed here in this area
and we are actually hovering around the
38.2 retracement level
which is what we're expecting in the
third wave you know we don't expect this
retracement to be too deep
and actually it should not last too long
so here what i'm a bit worried about
now let's talk about this very soon
first i want to show you guys
one more thing that i like to use is
pivot points what i call
pivot points is some support or
resistance
level obtained using trend lines that
are actually
you know some major levels so here
i'm saying this in most of my videos but
it's always good to repeat it maybe you
guys didn't watch my previous videos
so is the 173 i call it 175 because you
know the market lacks round numbers
but if you want to be precise you need
to find you know
i'm i'm obtaining this number by using
very old reactions i mean
two months ago and here you can see that
we did down to
173 here 172.5
here it's 173 so 173 is actually
the precise level and you can see guys
this is the beauty about
this kind of pivot points is that they
are very efficient for a long time
once you spot one it's very very useful
and here for example uh you can see that
we were it was acting as support all
this area and here it was acting as
resistance
once twice i don't know if you guys see
it properly but you know it's
very clean almost perfect here we just
you know broke it
like by maybe one percent but you know
on on such a
uh long term i mean medium term it's
very
useful to have this kind of pivot points
and you can see guys
it's not a surprise this is actually
what was acting as support
the whole week so we just have had on
the hourly time frame
a small breakdown here but once again
this kind of
long-term support or resistance levels
they need to be used uh on a you know at
least four hours time frame
and the four was time frame we got the
breakout but immediately
we traded above by quite a lot and then
it was intact so this level has not been
broken so it goes
in the same direction as the moving
averages as the field retracements
so this is very good now something else
i like to use guys because you always
need to be aware
that your buddhist case your preferred
scenario which he
here is bullish is not guaranteed all
right
so you cannot blind yourself and just
look at
the you know what you want to see
so here very quickly the alternative
scenario
is you know maybe it's not an abc like
this maybe it's an abc like this
and maybe this is not a third wave but
this is a whole you know
maybe this is not a one two three four
five
but maybe this is all w x y is here w
x y right this is possible and the y can
go here can go here so i don't know
and then here we would have you know
abc's like this
so abc and a b c
you see abc abc and abc
all right so even if we go to 216
actually it's the level i need to break
for this correction to be of the table
if we break 216
the wxy correction is off the table
which means that maybe we can still find
some bearish cases but this is the kind
of most likely bearish case
is the wxy correction so this is what
i'm looking at
and here actually the first signal that
i would
get that we might be still doing this
is here if it's not one two three four
five like i was showing you just before
you know if it's not like this
then the b wave here would be weaker and
longer and this would not be as
impulsive as it should be in the third
wave and
you know as i don't have the volumes
confirming me this information that we
are on the third wave
i still think about this scenario so for
this scenario to happen guys this is
where i wanted to bring you now is that
we're gonna have some
bearish signals and
one very good uh signal that is showing
you that the market
cannot do it that we don't have enough
energy which is actually liquidity
to you know push the price action higher
is the average answers
so i'm talking uh more and more about
those
indicators i mean this method that is
combining
price action and momentum indicators
because it's actually quite
difficult to understand it's you know
trend lines moving averages
fibs those are just basic rules
divergences are a bit more complex
because
you know you need to train your mind to
understand how it works and what signals
it's giving you
so let me show you quickly again it's
good to see this many times guys
so we have different type of divergences
i was showing you guys the bullish
regular divergence on the short term on
amc and the hidden divergence bullish as
well on amc on the longer term
on gamestop i didn't have any
divergences i didn't have any bullish
divergences i didn't have
any bearish divergences still the price
action went
higher so you don't always have those
you know
signals when the market is shifting but
80 of the time you're gonna find it so
let's try
to see let's check every thing let's not
blind ourselves and just pretend this is
bullish and
this cannot go down this can go down all
right
so we're gonna start on the hourly
timeframe because we're looking for
short-term divergence
and i'm gonna show you how to do it
properly because i'm pretty sure that
for you guys when i talk about
divergences you're like oh what is this
again we don't understand
okay so simple you have two types of
divergences as
like i showed you so first you connect
the highs
and then you connect the lows you know
that you only have two things to check
so we connect the highs in the moves
we're considering we're wondering if
this move is actually going to shift
so we measure it right from here to here
and we check what is the macd
doing during this move so 14th of april
it's like here to here all right
so the macd is going higher higher highs
higher macd
no divergences now we do the same thing
on the downside
so we connect the lows
and we connect the macd
so here 13th of april so it's something
somewhere around here
and here it is the 23rd of april okay so
you can see that
the the slope is weaker less steep
but still the macd is going higher
so no divergences all right so
we can even do it on the shorter term so
on the hourly timeframe we don't have
any divergences but let's check on the
five minutes time frame
be professional really check so we can
say that we really checked everything
and we're doing the same thing so you're
wondering about this move
so you just measure it so here i can see
right away from here to here
higher lows higher macd all right no
problem
and are we making higher highs we're
making higher highs
and is the macd here okay so here
you can see that we have a small
hidden divergence 28 of apple
i know it's good guys it's good
just right on it but we are not going
lower all right
okay this is you know we having a very
very light
hidden divergence bearish hidden
divergence but on the five minutes time
frame you know
maybe we already had the move or maybe
we're gonna have this abc i was talking
about so here
very slight hidden divergence but to be
honest
is not clear enough to be used this is
flat you know this is not very clear
signal so
i prefer to forget about it because when
you know the indicators you're having
are not giving you
strong signals it is not that relevant
to
use it so let's go back on the four
hours time frame
and on the four hours time frame i've
already looked for it i don't have any
divergences i will not
do it again so when else do we have
we don't have any bearish divergence
we're not gonna have buddhist we didn't
have buddhist divergence as well and
still we go higher
so that is not telling us hundred
percent sure that we're not gonna shift
lower
but for now we're having all the
different indicators
moving averages trend lines like pivot
points and
idiot wave counting that are pointing in
the direction that we're gonna go
higher next week so that's it for me i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to shore i see you guys